Earlier, we rewrote Grant's balance after one year as 10,000 times 1 plus 0.03.
Here, we can clearly see those two quantities we were just talking about. The
principle 10,000 right here, and the interest rate, 0.03 right here. So, what
would happen if we kept our expressions in this form, but found the balance
after year two? First things first, though, let's remember how we found this
quantity here. We took the principle, and then, since this is the amount of
money in the account at the start of this year, we multiplied it by the
interest rate. That's how we got this quantity. Now, we know that to find this
balance after two years, we're going to need to start with the amount of money
that's in the account at the beginning of year 2, which is this quantity right
here. So, this amount is going to sneak around and end up as our starting
point. Now, I'm about to give you a bunch of boxes to fill in, but please don't
be overwhelmed. You're very well-prepared to do what I'm about ask you to do.
It's not a big deal. What I would like you to do is to substitute into these
green boxes a certain quantity. And I'll give you a hint, the same quantity
belongs in each of these boxes. Think using this equation right here what
quantity that is. Then, based on what you end up with right here, I'd like you
to write this in a more compact form right here. However, keep 1 plus 0.03
written as is. Don't change it to 1.03.